okay so Elon Musk warned civilization is
over if Ukraine doesn't give in to
Russia okay
self-proclaimed political expert Elon
Musk obviously that comment means they
like him a lot has issued a stark
warning to Ukraine as Russia's Invasion
countries continues using Twitter the
platform he is likely to soon own and
control the world's richest man made a
number of eyebrow raising predictions
for eventualities regarding the outcome
of Russia's invasion of Ukraine if
Russia is faced with the choice of
losing Crimea or using Battlefield nukes
they will choose the latter the SpaceX
and Tesla Co tweeted the West has
already sanctioned cut off Russia in
every possible way so what more do they
have left to lose if we nuke Russia back
they will nuke us and then we have world
war three in short musk is arguing that
Ukraine should give in to Russia's
demand or else a highly controversial
perspective that has already landed him
in hot water recently last week he
announced SpaceX will no longer Supply
starlink Internet satellite Tech to
Ukraine a decision he reversed two days
later they're not saying why
one of their diplomats one of their
leaders told him to go f off that's why
he just canceled it but when when you
hear you know the experience and the
lack of proper decision making in
Afghanistan that you second guessed and
a lot of people also thinking yes you're
not alone there
and then we have this going on right now
where a guy like Elon Musk is commenting
how do you what do you think about what
Elon said and what do you think about
the way we've been handling Russia and
Ukraine
yeah so two very different questions so
first of all Crimea I mean Russia
annexed that way before the current
conflict that we're having here so I
think musses comments was they've
already annexed Crimea
just acknowledge give them that
um but then there's still a whole bunch
of contested area right now in the
Eastern portion of Ukraine and so
ultimately what musk is advocating for
is some concessions by Ukraine and you
know the ukrainians are been operating
the way they have for the last 60ish
years and and they don't want to go back
to russia-controlled territory I don't
know it's complicated so I would say my
opinion is that the United States a lot
of times can't get out of its own way
and makes matters worse and so I'm not
sure that the
billions and billions of dollars that
we've given Ukraine was it the best
return on investment I think in a lot of
ways it probably cripples our European
allies who should be doing the same
thing I mean there's no better example
of a pacified culture than the Germans
the Germans are right there and should
really in my opinion be doing a lot more
How This Ends I'm not sure I think
people are getting a little too
hysterical about Vladimir Putin not
being a rational human being
um I I I don't know if I agree with that
assessment I understand why he did what
he did with the advancement of NATO and
but I do believe it was a strategic
mistake I do believe he has old kbg
thinking
um KGB excuse me and so you know his old
style of thinking is more land equals
more power and that's just not true in
today's world today it's controlling the
beliefs of the people is the ultimate
power and if by going from more land he
polarizes all the beliefs of the people
he's actually degraded a lot of his
power I mean look no further than Sweden
and Norway to look at his strategic
failures so really what we're arguing
about is some border region areas and I
don't know how that will play out but
I'm I'm not convinced that Vladimir
Putin is not rational and I'm also not
convinced that we should be giving as
much money to Ukraine as we are what's
the likelihood you think of this thing
getting ugly the way Elon says if we
make a couple bad moves this guy goes
first
we retaliated can turn into a world war
three what's the likelihood of that I
think it go it comes back to the the
beliefs of the people and so I think
people in America often want to project
Russians as these evil people Russians
are you know
very much like us white Christian
European type people like if you
actually hang out with a Russian they
they are they are very kind to Americans
and like Americans right if I went into
a Muslim country like Iran uh they would
not be as kind and they would have a
different belief system same thing with
the Chinese and so
I'm I guess I'm just not convinced that
the Russian people are gonna allow it to
happen but you know crazier things have
happened is it a threat that we should
be worried about absolutely but Elon
Musk uh projecting that Vladimir Putin
is completely irrational therefore we
must concede certain things I think is
maybe a stretch did you hear the rumor
that came out Tyler last week that
they're saying musk had a conversation
with Putin
I've heard that briefly did you hear
about this last week away Elon Musk had
a conversation with Putin you know an
article saying did Elon Musk speak with
Vladimir Putin I don't know if uh
can you zoom in a little bit
um he's not repeating and Putin talking
point he's a he's a Putin asset because
the guy doesn't want to do anything to
piss off let me read this story from
1945 that just came out a couple days
ago Biden's Ukraine strategy could start
a nuclear war with Russia what too many
of our current leaders and enthusiastic
in Washington Hawks uh somehow failed to
recognize however is that unlike all our
military opponents of the past several
decades Russia's possession of nuclear
weapons means they can in a moment of
desperation of fear initiate a nuclear
war
that could quite literally wipe the
United States out of existence obviously
that's hard
exaggeration but you know this is what
the writer is saying this should not
this should not be hard to understand if
the US and NATO finally provide enough
Firepower intelligence and training to
Ukrainian troops
that will enable them to physically
Drive Russian forces completely out of
Ukraine territories especially the
highly charged emotional areas of
donbass and Crimea Putin will be forced
into a corner where he has to choose
between allowing his entire force to be
completely defeated or escalate to use
of nuclear weapons what do you think
about what this article says
yeah I mean that's a that's a theory I I
I'm obviously not Vladimir Putin
um but I don't know if I agree there's a
way I think for him to save face uh
without giving him all of the donbass
area I mean I'm not a geography major
I've looked at it on a map seems to be a
pretty big area I mean here he already
has Crimea and I think quite honestly
we've already defeated him strategically
like even if he comes out of this with
parts of the Don boss
I don't know if he sees it as a victory
so like let's define that what is
Victory and what is complete defeat for
him I mean I don't know I I would submit
holding on to Crimea uh might not be a
complete defeat and there's probably
ways where we could come to the table
and make it not look like he completely
got defeated Maybe I'm Wrong
yeah I think that's the that's the real
question right right yeah exactly what
do you do for him to say face because
this is not a regular guy that's you
know he's go he cannot be publicly
offended yeah and and that's what it's
looking like Tom history you've been you
you followed stories like this for a
while how do you
what do you think is the proper way to
do something here where at least you you
please him but also at the same time
you're not doing something where you're
giving him everything he wants well I
think there's a lot of examples of this
that happen in the the resolutions of
the arab-israeli wars when you go back
and take a look like when Egypt came
across Suez Canal and Opera and then
occupied West Bank and remember what
happened was the Israelis pushed them
all the way back into the canal over the
canal and then took part of Egypt's land
on the other side and what you had to do
here is Israel is like I'm not giving
back the land on the other side of the
canal because now I have a buffer
against a known demonstrated aggressor
and so I'm going to extend the buffer
here and there's negotiations that had
to take place to make it literally a
demilitarized zone that Israel only
would accept policing that was 100
demilitarized by Egyptian forces and you
had to give Anwar Sadat even though he
was the aggressor a face saving
otherwise the people these Egyptian
people that just at their core of their
heart hate Israel you know we're not
going to be happy they're going to be
rioting so you had to balance both
things for the ego of the leader as well
as the response to the people and I
think that's exactly the delicate thing
that had to happen here and the West had
to whisper to Israel and say listen you
took it back fair and square they came
across and you literally kicked the crap
out of them for seven days with U.S
equipment uh you're nodding you know the
history I do and then they came back and
they said okay we're gonna come back
across but this will now be a completely
demilitarized zone there can be no
Egyptians that are armed in the area but
they can police it up to the old border
so the old Border was restored but
without presence of any military assets
which is what the only thing that the
Israelis would allow there can be no
military assets there because you've
demonstrated what you do with them and
so it saved face for Sadat it saved the
people being the the militant part of
the people from being an open conflict
the way they are constantly now it you
know on the other side of Jerusalem
where you have the three territories
that are never at peace and I think
that's exactly what has to happen here A
A an international Diplomat has to step
up find a way for him to save face maybe
let him keep Crimea and then pull back
on this because you've got you've got
this leader and it's happened before in
history we have rational people around
the world can come together to make to
to D to defuse what could be a second
bomb can I ask a question historically
what have been moments where a person
who played a role of a diplomat or
somebody that just was a unifier that
held a meeting between uh in the middle
of war that held a meeting between two
of the hated leaders or presidents or
prime ministers come together
historically how often has it happened
you think of people like Kissinger you
know who was a who was us but he was
seen as this he was really seen as a as
a old school you know ambassadorial
light touch Diplomat he was our guy and
he was U.S but he was able to he was
able to negotiate who's that guy today
with soft skills that can have these
types of conversations I think you go
back I I don't know well today I don't
know well two a couple different points
I'm gonna go blinking is not not talking
about well the first thing that comes to
mind was Clinton sitting down with
Yasser arafah and the attack Rabin
Israel PLO uh these days uh former
governor of New Mexico Bill Richardson
he's kind of sent all around the world
to get hostage out of uh enemy countries
um but to Tom's Point uh not to deviate
I don't know if you guys saw um on Bill
Maher this weekend they had uh Bibi
Netanyahu the former prime minister of
Israel you've spent some time in the
Israeli Lebanon conflict clicked in mid
2000s
the My ultimate question to Tom is that
example that you gave of the Suez Canal
and the Sinai Peninsula of Israel and
Egypt it's actually a great example the
only difference is now this guy's got
nukes and Putin has a much much much
bigger ego questionably a fragile more
fragile Eagle than
um Anwar Sadat so how do you grapple
with the fact that he's as he's such a
large World presence social media is so
much more Amplified everyone's eyeballs
on Ukraine versus an Egypt situation
before social media and he's got nukes
so yeah is it really a fair analogy I
think the human side of it is identical
just the tools and consequences are
worse because the tools are bigger but
the human side of it is the same and I I
also go back and I give credit to Jimmy
Carter and the Camp David Peace Accords
and I believe his guy was the big new
Brzezinski Mika brzezinski's Dad yes
right zinski yep I think he was our guy
that yeah that broke her big time Big
Time at that who didn't need newspaper
headlines didn't want a book deal but he
quietly made it happen
um and I think to your question Pat
that's the kind of guy we need right now
I have two points I want to make on this
so first I've been holding on to this
sadak comment I think Sadat and Putin
it's I understand the point you're
making but Sadat literally just wanted
to cross the Suez as like a a show of
force I don't think he ever wanted to
gain territory he just wanted to show
the Muslim world that he could cross the
Suez and then literally as Israel was
beating them back
he was declaring Victory because it was
more of a show whereas Putin I think you
know you wants to use violence and gain
territory so I've been sitting here
thinking you know how could we you know
give on this so Elon musk's
recommendation is strictly land-based
you know concessions of land literally
the reason what is driving Putin is not
uh maniacal Madness it's because he sees
natives expansion as a threat so if if
the West is going to concede something I
think the Don bass and the Crimea is
much less important than you know the
threat that NATO poses to Putin so quite
honestly you know if the United States
wanted to to end this war right now they
could say hey United States is pulling
out of NATO we're going to take all
those forces put them on our own
Southern border you guys figure it out
Putin says I'm okay with that and he
goes back to Russia I mean you could
solve that with something like that but
the problem is
so many people are invested in NATO that
that would also be a hard sell but that
would be a way you could de-escalate it
do you not think that it's vital for the
United States to be a major part of NATO
I think I would pull out of NATO
completely I think now do I think a
strong presence in the global Arena
establishes order yes do I think that
America has set the world tone for the
last century yes do I think NATO has
extremely crippled our European allies
yes and so why crippled be just the
budget is probably the biggest one right
if we weren't there providing as you
know 80 percent of the budget yeah then
they would be forced to spend more this
was essentially Trump's argument for
years yes
exactly pay your bill yeah pay your bill
but he Trump was just advocating for
them to pay their three percent right
right and they weren't even doing that I
don't think Trump went far enough and
quite honestly with you know everyone
can't figure out how to to fix our
Southern border you don't even need to
build a wall just take all those NATO
forces that are across Europe and put
them on our Southern border and I could
solve the problem in a month like but
that's what we do so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]